[Music]
hello Conan O'Brien here and I'm gonna
answer your second question today the
question comes from Mary Williams she's
a freshman at the University of Central
Florida
here's Mary's question Konan can you do
my astronomy homework for me and she
actually sent the homework well Mary I
want to help I don't know much about
astronomy so I brought in a heavy hitter
meet dr. Evan Kirby dr. Kirby good to
see you how are you good alright now
first of all let me the straight you are
a Hubble fellow at Caltech that's right
okay how old are you I'm 28 years old no
you're not I think you're 14 years old
are you a boy genius no well what did
you did you develop an interest in
astronomy at a very early age really
were you like 2 years old and your first
word was Copernicus Copernicus father
tell me more all right I have a question
and I'd like you to answer it this is
for Mary okay here we go
which of the following best describes
why the sun's spectrum contains black
lines over an underlying rainbow number
one the sun's hot interior produces a
continuous rainbow of color but cooler
gas at the surface absorbs light at
particular wavelengths number two the
rainbow colors represent emissions by
particular chemical elements while the
black lines represent gaps were no
element can emit light number three the
Sun produces a continuous rainbow of
color while the black lines are caused
by imperfections and the instruments
used to record the spectrum number four
the Sun produces a continuous rainbow of
color while the black lines are caused
by atoms and molecules in the Earth's
atmosphere any idea number one that the
sun's hot interior produces a continuous
rainbow of color but cooler gas the
surface absorbs the light a particular
wavelengths why can you explain and we
paid a lot of money for this can you
just use it if you take white light yes
we all know that by the way light yeah
yeah and you break it up into its colors
yes yes okay how you make a B that's L
oh you just that's lalu okay
you are 11 aren't you okay what should
pretend that to be but continue yeah
you have different intensities that each
color of course you do we all know that
yes and if you have iron or some other
element in the sun's atmosphere then
that iron or some other atom can absorb
light at a very particular color that
looks dirty
you just made a dirty picture there's a
penis sorry but it does does that happen
a lot in class do people snicker
whenever you draw that all the time iron
it looks sort of like a phallic image
okay I think you're insane your theories
are mad you're a madman you're crazy
get out get out anyway if you have any
other questions go to facebook.com slash
team Coco I will answer them for you he
didn't even leave look he's still here
it's just cowering in the corner thanks
doc
[Music]